Oh
well preparing for a dive takes
different forms depending on what kind
of dive you're going to do if you're
just going to go snorkeling or holding
your breath diving down no preparation
needed just take a big breath and down
you go of course it's nice to have a
face mask it helps to have flippers it
helps if you're in cold water to have a
wetsuit or even a dry suit that'll keep
you warm if you want to stay more than
just a moment or two for using scuba you
will first want to make sure that you
have air in your tank that again the
same old thing if you want to be warm
cold diving in cold water you've got to
prepare for that using self-contained
underwater breathing apparatus scuba
requires a little bit of training not a
lot the more you do it the more
comfortable you are the more experienced
the more able you are to cope with the
unexpected so circumstances arise but
mainly it's very simple my instruction
back in 1953 before there were classes
in learning how to dive it was very
simple two words breathe naturally and
don't hold your breath because if you do
hold your breath while you have
compressed air that you have taken in
while breathing and you ascend the air
that's in your body in your lungs and
your tissues will expand as you come
closer to the surface as you begin to
take the pressure off that's dangerous
you can embolize you can get bubbles in
your bloodstream you can get the bends
so breathe naturally was really good
advice because as you exhale you
eliminate the air that you have in your
lungs and so you learn not to stay too
long
because after a while the air that you
breathe the nitrogen actually gets into
your bloodstream forms little bubbles
and you can stay for a short period of
time and all of this is closely
calculated you know exactly how long you
could say before you have to
count in decompression before coming
back to the surface a lot of this has
been learned in the last 50 years the
hard way by people who have made
mistakes who have tried it and have
learned that they need to do things
differently I have been part of that
learning curve I suppose in 1974 the
first time I had a chance to live
underwater they call it saturation
diving you stay underwater at a certain
depth long enough for your tissues to
become saturated with the breathing mix
that inhaling in the case of the first
case it wasn't just air it was a mixture
of nitrogen and oxygen with somewhat
less oxygen that we have at the surface
and therefore a little more nitrogen
because oxygen actually can become toxic
if you breathe it under pressure for a
long time at a certain depth below about
30 feet 60 feet it is it becomes toxic
dangerous you can go into convulsions if
you have too much oxygen you how can you
have too much oxygen you might think we
need oxygen we do but too too much
oxygen even for us under the right or
wrong circumstances can be lethal can
certainly be harmful so these are all
things that in the process of learning
how to dive you can learn and figure out
and then but it's a bit like using a
telephone we take for granted that you
can pick it up and talk into it
Engineers have carefully crafted the
technology so that it is easy to use
mechanisms so you can just breathe into
a regulator and not actually have to
understand how it works if you trust
your and the engineers and I've come to
rely on engineers through much of what
I've done to gain access to the sea I
try to understand how the processes work
so that if something goes wrong I can
react and adjust accordingly but since I
personally am NOT an engineer I tried
work with them to do the heavy lifting
when it comes to doing the calculations
getting those systems so that they will
work when they need to work it goes for
scuba apparatus it goes for little
submarines that I've had the joy of
using I've been on the inside track of
building submarines so I do kind of
understand what it takes but I leave the
actual calculations to those who know
more about it than I do